patrick corbin tonight quality starts in
four of his last five outings last start
july 7th at san diego was the 15 to five
winner two runs on seven hits over six
endings
and a lead off walk for tommy pham to
get it started for the friars
here is fernando tatis jr fly ball
headed to
short right field incoming is soto but
that's gonna fall
and the second base goes fam he had to
wait to make sure that was gonna fall
and so now the cyclist jake cronenworth
two on and nobody out
3-2 is lined into left field a base hit
coming around from second base is fam he
will score throw goes to second
and jake chronoworth has driven in the
game's first run padres take a
one-nothing lead in the first inning
first and third nobody out padres you
have the game's first run and here is
manny machado
lifts it in the air shallow left out as
a shortstop turner
and he'll make the catch and foul ground
and trying to score from third is tatis
the throw not in time fernando gets in
shallow left with a pop-up and fernando
tags up and scores
terrific jump good throw by turner the
question is does
tatis get his foot in ahead of renee
rivera's slide he doesn't even get a
slide it looks like
a tag it looks like i think yeah i think
you're exactly right i think he missed
so no challenge what a terrific read by
fernando runners first and second one
out and now the left-hand inning
trent grisham coming up ground ball nats
will try and turn it
escobar turner and patrick corbin's out
of the first inning on the bound for the
padres already with a two-nothing lead
is blake snell
fresh off the il blake snell comes into
this game with a 499 era three and three
on the year
so a one-hour walk to the speedy turner
who's second in the national league and
steals with 19 and 22 tries
but not likely to run when juan soto is
hot at the plate
there he goes swinging a mess and soto
strikes out
no throw to second base no chance at
second base to get turner
and a couple of passes me and two
runners with two outs for josh harris in
the left fielder
drills this one to center and it's down
here comes trey he will score standing
up
and the nats are on the board two to one
here in the first a little answer here
with the clutch two out knock
josh harrison gets a run on the board
first knock of the knife for the net
scores trey turner
2-1 padres have a lead over the
nationals here's blake he's got a
one-game hitting streak swings the first
pitch guess what two-game hitting streak
punches it through the left side for a
base hit two on two down here's fernando
3-0 swinging will send it into center
field for a base hit
blake snell's coming around throw will
be cut off snell will score in the
padres have their two-run lead back
again
on top three to one all of this coming
with two outs
second hit of the night for and he'll
pick up an rbi padres take a 3-1 lead
audrey's on top three-to-one andy
machado getting it started here in the
third
and a fly ball in the air to deep left
field back goes harrison
onto the dirt of the track at the wall
drops the baseball
bounces around as machado to second base
with a double
harrison getting back there didn't make
the catch
purely a home run there for machado
there's a grounder back up the middle
into center field base head
machado be stopped at third
nobody out and now a throw to second
base and safe there is myers he gets in
and the throw going play ward so will
decides he's going to try to get a
second and does successfully
second and third one away here's hassan
kim
fly ball on a liner to left field
that'll get to the wall
coming around from third to score is
machado here comes myers
to second base with a stand-up double is
hassan kim
padres take a 5-1 lead kim drives in a
pair
terrific job getting on this first pitch
heater he brings across two more runs
and the line keeps moving for this padre
ball club
two on nobody out nationals threatening
here in the third and zimmerman coming
up
he walked in the first inning turner
takes off soto behind him and zimmerman
lifts one to center
back is grisham it's gone three-run
homer for ryan zimmerman
these teams cannot stop scoring in this
series
it's five to four and number eleven can
still do it kenny
two on nobody out three runs in so far
here's renee rivera
ground ball to shortstop tatista's
second for one on to first for two
well he needed that lake snell really
just one out away from getting out of
this inning
that one looked like it hit victor
robles on a bounce harrison's going to
come in anyway
and no indication from home plate umpire
jordan baker
robles is going to first harrison has
crossed home plate that cannot
coexist both of those things cannot
happen but there was the slider in the
dirt
and it did get his elbow guard oh second
and
third with two down kicks and deals and
a swing and a miss strike three to get
him out of the inning
nationals said eight men to the plate
here's tatis
her ball is grounded through a vacated
right side into right field of base hit
just a check swing
and tati's gonna try to take two on it
and he will stays on the back
little check swing excuse me ground ball
base hit turns into two
for none other than fernando tatis
junior this guy's amazing
i'm telling you we've got young kids
watching this game
this is the guy you want to have him
watch two on one out of the inning
ground ball right side zim will go to
the backhand he'll flip to second for
the out turner
to corbin covering corbin stumbles on
the catch but holds on
and the nationals turn to double play
3-6-1
dubits are on for the padres as we move
to the bottom of the fifth inning craig
stamen
ground ball right side ranging is kim
from the outfield grass we'll get it
there in time
as rangy play from hassan kim for the
first out of the fifth runner at second
one out now the pitch to mercer
and a ground ball towards the left side
tatis big hop checks the runners zips
his throw to first just in time
and fernando just uh blew the smoke off
the top of his gun
watch fernando set his feet and let off
a missile across the field
you can afford to set your feet and let
off a shotgun like that
as he puts it back in the holster so two
on one out for fernando tatis jr doing
it offensively doing it defensively
it's a fly ball to left field and that's
going to be off the bottom of the wall
coming around from second is reboss he
will score the third goes fam
it's a long single off the wall in left
rbi
single at that for tatis and the padres
take a 6-4 lead
a four-hit game for fernando
there he goes and no throw just the
bluff and fernando steal second base
so now runners on second and third and a
three-two count to cronenworth
and cronenworth sends one through the
left side into left field to base hit
fam will score
tatisse is stopped and he'll be safe
able to get back somehow again boy they
had him at third watch the footwork here
by fernando tatis
completely dekes turner a little euro
step if you will
see that move in basketball far more
than you do in baseball but
again the kid can do a lot of things on
the baseball field that no one else can
now with two outs and tati's still at
third base
little bloop into center it's gonna fall
from third comes fernando
padres taking 8-4 lead manny machado
kind of dunks one in to shallow center
it's a different feel at the ballpark
today
baseball will be played at nationals
park but all of us still thinking about
the events
of yesterday a shooting outside
nationals park yesterday's game
suspended in the middle of the sixth
inning a shooting outside a nationals
park
not at all related to the nationals game
here or nationals park in general
turner has walked stolen base scored a
run
single to center and scored a run
on the ground to third and machado
backing up on that goes to second base
for the fourth
out and will end the sixth inning
audrey's up eight to four in the top of
the seventh two on and two out for tommy
pham
fly ball to shallow right that is going
to get in for a base hit
there comes reboss he'll score the ninth
padres run
throw to the plate gets away and now
hosmer is going to try and score
hosmer coming in and the padres make it
10-4
so one run scoring on the base hit by
fam the errant throw will lead to
another and the padres into double
figures in runs on top ten to four
adam struck out mercer struck out rivera
now a full count to
victor robles swinging a foul tip for
strike three
nicely done so we'll take something from
ryan zimmerman if we are to continue
with two away
swinging a miss and diaz strikes out
zimmerman to end the ball game
two strikeouts in the inning for diaz as
the padres win the first
ten to four is the final the suspended
game
is over